foreign
[Music]
hello open the door let's let everybody
in
folks you are tuning in to daily with
Doc I am so excited to have a full room
here on you uh Zoom that's where we are
we're recording so if you would like to
join us and if you have a question that
you would like of Dr Joel Wallach and
get the answer based on his research and
not just the research but actually
putting his research into action in his
clinics
and through Distributors like myself and
all of my co-hosts
and getting results
so if you'd like to join us here on
daily with Doc in the actual recording
room come to daily with Doc
zoom.com that is daily with
doczoom.com so I know the people here in
the zoom room with me is like well we're
already here I'm talking to the people
out in YouTube and Rumble and Facebook
come on over we are so happy to be able
to offer this program and the best part
about it is all the people that are
commenting on the videos that are
sharing the videos and using this
as a resource to share a message that
empowers people instead of taking the
power away from people we're all about
empowering people so they can do things
in their own lives that benefit
themselves physically mentally
emotionally and for those of you who
choose to join us in the business
financially and actually Dr Wallach
even if people are just using the
products they can benefit financially
because it's helping to avoid
all of those 600 plus conditions that
you found to be nutrient related
nutrient deficient and they both show
prices and we pay the shipping if they
get on auto ship
there you go
well
this program is being sponsored by daily
with Doc and we are proud to be able to
have the replays from our past
shows
dealing with Doc I stock live Watchdog
daily
um also the Q a was pharmacist Ben so if
you're ever looking for any of those
past recordings or you want to do a
search and try to find something that is
specific to what you're looking for you
can go to daily with doc.com
and do a search there and you'll be able
to find our past recordings we also have
many of them out on YouTube and Rumble
and Facebook in our group that's the
critical health and critical Health news
channels so it's critical Health news on
Rumble and YouTube and then critical
Health on Facebook so go ahead and reach
out and like and follow so if you're on
YouTube hit that follow subscribe we
want to make sure that
um we're reaching people and we want to
see how many people we're actually
reaching so we have questions here in
YouTube already Dr Wallach we have hands
up with us here in zoom and folks if you
are with us here in zoom and you'd like
to ask a question go to that reactions
button in the zoom menu click on raise
hand and we will be going through and
calling on people in the order that
their hands are received and we're going
to try to
Dr Wallach has his hand up folks but
it's this it's this hand I'm gonna let
him have a slide but I'm still going to
call out him so Dr Wallach
you have a Bachelor of Science in
agriculture you studied plants
and in that you were also studying
animals
so we've got plants we've got animals
you were looking at the nutritional
deficiencies or you were just like doing
pathology reports trying to figure out
why things were dying
and you found that there were
nutritional deficiencies with specific
conditions
or pollution
so the science of epigenetics proves
that there's no genetic
diseases
and the transmission of it is through
nutrient deficiencies
not your genes
epigenetics hey I have that book
here it is I think oh well yeah you've
got it and I'm supposed to have it right
here I think somebody borrowed it from
me
but so epigenetics Dr Wallach
tell us a little bit about epigenetics
you can go ahead and put the book down
um I will find my copy but I love the
picture of the the little Reese monkey
that you're holding that's looking up to
you and it's like it's like a father-son
relationship where that baby
is looking up to you because he trusts
you it's I love I love that picture Dr
Wally well thank you tell us a little
bit about it and then I know that you've
got a topic that we're going to talk
about that I think is going to touch a
lot of people today too yes okay well
um I had a job in 1976 at the Yorkies
Primary Center at Emory University in
Atlanta Georgia as a pathologist and I
got that job because of my previous
position at Washington University in St
Louis Missouri along with Barnes
Hospital in the St Louis Zoo Marlin
Perkins
um Marlon Perkins had taken my first
published scientific article where I did
a
an article on a mass die off of sheep
because of pollution it was a pollution
thing and it was the first massed out
pollution article written in the United
States okay and um
he took that and got a 21 million dollar
Grant from NIH National institutional
health and I did my 20 000 autops my
first not my first but mass of twenty
thousand autopsy project for over 10
years at Morrison University in St Louis
uh published it uh dozens of times you
know different articles and things
and the um the reason why I got that job
at Yorkie's Primary Center there's all
these monkeys are sending into space
with the space people and they wanted to
really know every detail any diseases a
single hair in their body would have or
there's any other at that point I was um
the most uh published of
um uh authors when it came to primates
and stuff like that so that's why they
picked me for that job
well
there's only there for a couple of
months and I ran into what I saw as the
first case a non-human case of cesium
ribosis thought to be one of the most
terrible
genetic birth defects in humanity
and I traced it back and and saw that it
wasn't a genetic disease it was a simple
nutritional deficiency
and I got I sent slides from that monkey
to five medical schools and I didn't
tell them they were from monkeys I just
said I think these slides are from a
cystic fibrosis patient what do you
think and they all sent back on their
letterheads
um and again this is 1976. uh yes these
are classic examples of Celia Bros and I
told them this is from a monkey this is
probably the first non-human case ever
published and they were so excited they
said yeah I think uh I I know what's
going on here and I think I can um
you know get you more and we'll have a
reservoir of baby monkeys which is a
grocery study it oh they were so excited
and then I got permission with all that
information to do biopsies and all the
other baby monkeys in the in the um your
keys Primary Center and they all had
physical brosis and so when I wrote it
up to present it in a national pathology
meeting for the United States government
um and I have pointed out that all these
monkeys have Cigar brosis they weren't
related to each other and it was due to
a nutritional deficiency which I had
traced to a deficiency of a single
nutrient and they fired me so while I
hear on your mind you must be
specifically because everybody knows
physical roast is one of the most
terrible genetic birth defects in humans
you're gone so they fired me make alone
three shark and went to all these
various events uh on the weekends trade
shows and things looking for a job and I
got a job to teach nutrition up in
Portland Oregon at the naturopathic
College up there and I said well I might
as well you know get the degree in
Nature Valley Medicine and become a
physician and they gave me some credit
for my pathology my nutrition and
um
those kinds of things
and so anatomy and so on and so um by
1982 I graduated as a Nature Valley
doctor okay and the whole idea was to
get this information out because I found
out there were no genuine transmitted
diseases none zero Zippo my thesis is at
that time I came out in 1985 I was in
Africa when it came out my thesis Marlon
Perkins and my publication on that
monkey came out in in 1985 also okay and
and Perkins
um I got that 20 21 million dollar Grant
with that thesis another was a thesis
with that article and in the thesis is
20 20 000 autopsies
and it was like crazy
because I proved that none of the things
they thought were genetic were genetic
they're almost as simple nutritional
efficiencies is my thesis
sells for it's called the diseases of
exotic animals
okay you can find a few used ones every
once in a while for three thousand five
thousand eight thousand uh dollars but
the new one's still in the box never
opened up sell for 25 to 35
000 and you know only big corporations
in medical schools can afford to buy
them no that's not it
I know this is not it well it's a
summary of chapter one
but this is the summary of your study at
the Reese monkey yeah this oh that's
starting on page 2016 if you get that
book primate 206 yeah 206 start there
read 206 to 215 and it goes through all
that stuff I just discussed in great
detail and Publications and scientific
journals that came out of it and then
you can go back to the beginning and
start this book from the beginning
because if you start at the beginning
you'll quit reading it by the third
chapter because why do you want to know
about parasites and monkeys why do you
want to know about anesthesia and
chimpanzees and stuff like that you're
not going to want to know that so you're
going to want to go to chapter or excuse
me page 206 where you start with all my
discoveries uh showing the mistakes that
the medical assistant was making about
genetics and so forth now
the story gets better here I'm going to
jump to a couple of months ago okay I'm
going to jump to a couple of months ago
um where we came out with um a new book
it's called the Wallach Revolution okay
and I think Becca's got one of those
there you go well like Revolution it's a
75-year journal okay of all the big
discoveries that I've made and the
forward was written by
let's see here A guy by the name of
let's see here uh Pat Boone yeah Pat
Boone Pat Boone he wrote that uh forward
because he had terrible arthritis he
went to the best doctors and so forth
and he they just want to you know give
knee Replacements and leg amputations
and all kind of stuff and I used the
Theo Ratliff
um approach on him the program that we
had built for Theo rattle uh rebuilt him
he came back cured of all his arthritis
and he wrote the the forward for this
book as a result of that he is so
excited that he didn't have to have his
legs amputated and all that kind of
stuff and then the the afterwards the
last chapter of the book is called the
afterward okay or
um
um Pat Boone wrote the the forward and
then Danny Glover wrote the afterward
now Danny Glover uh as a child I mean
we're talking two three years old had
terrible seizures uh he is diagnosed
with um epilepsy and all this kind of
stuff you know all through his teenage
life he was on all these drugs and
everything he's always breakthroughs it
was a mess
and
we actually put him on our program and
cheered him of all his problems and so
you know and Danny Glover of course is a
famous comedian and singer and so forth
and and
um uh Pat Boone is very famous singer he
sings one of my favorite songs the theme
song for the movie Exodus uh 1960 he
sang that one and Rebecca got me a uh I
don't know what he would call it she got
a collection of many of Pat Boone's
songs uh it's breathless all the great
songs he did and of course he's sang
many of these songs from Exodus on this
thing that Rebecca gave me
but um these things are unimpeachable
evidence in this book excuse me the the
revolution everybody needs to get this
book because it shows and it tells a
kind of uh what did I say a summary of
the story of Theo Ratliff how he was in
terrible trouble with his arthritis and
he launched his big 35 million dollar
contract okay from the Atlanta Hawks
he's only 24 years old he had bone to
bone arthritis his knees and his hips
and he had fractures and a shooting arm
wrist at his right hand and they took
his contract away and say you're done
there's nobody in any
a professional team wants you because
you're so broken down we came up with
the healthy Bone and Joint pack which
was our Healthy Start pack and I had to
come up with a first collagen project
product which was a glucogel and added
that to the Healthy Start pattern we
call it a healthy Bone and Joint pack
and then came up with our rebound for
him
and he just took it and ran with it and
was did such a wonderful job
in putting all this together and so the
Theo and I lectured
uh you know on radio TV all over the
world before games after games and so on
and he played professional basketball
for 11 years here's a guy who was
supposed to be a wreck and couldn't you
know play basketball uh I don't know a
dozen times annually he was the
um
what should I say the award-winning shot
blocker he was also one of his scores in
the National NBA uh and so we we thank
him and Rebecca and I and Thea were
putting together
this is his 50th birthday this year so
he put together an interview last week
yep last week okay we did an interview
with him and brought it up to date you
know we're 21 new years which we called
it the 20-year anniversary of working
with Hill uh Ratliff and so soon this is
going to be available to everybody to
know what he went through with all these
diseases we got rid of with nutrition
okay and then you talk about the
revolution where you're talking about
um Pat Boone and Danny Glover who tell
their story they tell their stories it's
not like they just say a statement and
they're telling their stories okay and
so this should be a great great thing
for Humanity to get this information
because there's so many things we can do
for them and it's all published and of
course if you buy 10 of any of these
titles at one time you get a nice
discount so I urge you to do that
and you can get if you want to give them
the information promote me to
well yeah we can if any of Dr wallach's
books Publications you can get it
drjwalik.com that's d r like doctor J
wallick.com
and I was having a conversation with
Theo Dr Wallach a couple days ago and
because I wanted to know exactly okay
how many years has it been so I'm saying
20 plus year anniversary because he's
turning 50. he said you know even though
I was having issues
it's about yeah he's 24. he said but
even when I before I got into the MBA I
was starting to have issues and they
still took a chance on me
and I'm so glad that they took a chance
on you on him because that if they
hadn't and if he wouldn't have been in
the NBA and started having problems then
people wouldn't have known about it and
reached out to him and introduced him to
you
and made the impact on what can actually
be possible
when it comes to joints
because he was breaking down yeah Theo
and I with his uh healthy Bone and Joint
pack and the rebound
we can save the world
okay it's one of those things
um and this is true life stuff as you
said this is not just theory in a
laboratory this is this is true life
stuff and we have helped so many
thousands literally thousands of people
who followed Theo's
um in his footsteps and taking the
programs and then of course that led to
getting rid of all kinds of birth
defects which I'm so proud of
yeah Dr Wallach it just amazes me how
difficult we make something that's
actually simple
yes and of course once you know what the
trail is you stick on the trail
you don't get lost you try and do silly
things you get off the trail
you get lost and so again
um this this is an endless Victory this
is an endless Victory this will go on
forever and
um people say well I'm surprised it's a
medical association and medical doctors
groups haven't sued you well they don't
want to take me to court
because that would be big front page
stories that would be big stuff and
guess who would win
yeah you've got a pretty good lawyer I
kind of like him
um
so yeah I I love the fact that I can
call Jonathan a friend and his wife as
well Dr Wallach they are a power team
when it comes to health wellness and
making sure that the truth gets out
there without the infringement on your
constitutional rights for those of you
who are in the United States now don't
they don't they also have something to
do with the
um his wife is a founder of The
Institute of holistic health there you
go yes
so she's one of the co-founders her and
Paul crotto
um two of the leaders within youngevity
and yourself so there's three founders
earlier of
I'm a leader but I'm not a co-founder Dr
while like I just keep the wheels
rolling make sure everything works
you're a coach
so I coach I train the coaches yes and
and it's amazing program because you do
not have to be in youngevity to go
through this health coach program
this is open to anybody and everybody we
want to make sure that Dr wallach's
message what he found in his research
is known worldwide
so if you're interested in getting more
information about being a certified
holistic health coach with the Institute
of holistic health get back with the
person that shared this program with you
if there's nobody to think go to
coachwithbecca.com and Becca's Becca so
coach with becca.com and there's more
information about our certified holistic
health coach course there
well Dr Wallach did you have anything
more that you wanted to add to your
opening this morning because we've got
hands up we've got questions let's go
let's go let's go to the hands and you I
just want to make sure that people know
they could get the story from Pat Boone
and Danny Glover in the book The Walk
Revolution and of course the book
epigenetics
um they kind of go together
well and it also talks about the the
times that you have gone up against the
FDA Dr Wallace that's correct and that's
how so I think that's an important part
of it yeah okay now let me since you
brought that up by doing that I got rid
of physical brosis okay we've already
talked about that I got rid of mustard
this fee worked with Jerry Lewis he was
my hero because he worked day and night
to find the cure for most fishing kids
they were always called Jerry's Kids
right and
um Marvin rob a Navy SEAL and I were
working in Indiana where they had such a
high rate amongst the Amish uh people
there of most history we were curing
them right left and Center okay and
figured out what the cause was and we
got it written up and um
got it got it published okay and uh they
wouldn't let us put these nutrients into
the baby formulas and so that's where
Jonathan anymore came in we went to uh
the federal court we sued the FDA Food
Drug Administration eight times in
federal court we prevailed every time
and we're able to then put these
nutrients into the baby Farmers Enfamil
and Similac and we got rid of
scissorbrosis we got rid of muscles we
in unbeknownst to us we also got rid of
what
I don't know sudden infant crypto cystic
fibrosis muscular dystrophy
well that's sudden infant crib yeah
syndrome
SIDS okay and we got rid of that so
those three diseases we got rid of by
putting essentially one nutrient into
baby firm which is one nutrient
and deficiency was causing those three
diseases
and I got the
um two awards for that one was the Chloe
Schwartz award uh there you go uh
um and
um the gold medal for that
um as Gerhard shrouds are probably
probably my hero in Biochemistry uh
giving me that metal I could just tell
you I was breathless when he gave me
that medal for finding the contrary
and SIDS and then that was in 2011 and
in 2015 I got a similar award from the
United Nations called the Lifetime
Achievement Award for me either Nations
okay for discovering those things
I'm so very proud of that and uh I can't
thank everybody enough who are involved
in those things because uh the awards
are nice but they represent saving kids
they represent that's that was to me
one's entire life is worth when you can
say we saved thousands of kids
I agree Dr Wallach and yes you found
the cause the prevention The Cure that's
correct
folks it's our job to make sure the
world hears about it
it's our job
there is no better form of communication
than word of mouth and sharing with
others
so I encourage I Empower you all to
share the message that you do not have
to be chained or a prisoner of a broken
system
so Dr Wallach Let's help some people
let's go for it let's go for it so the
first thing and this was this came up
before any hands came up
um so we have somebody in the YouTube
realm here who
um was at end stage kidney disease
has improved to chronic kidney disease
stage three they are wanting to know
what can be done to support
the function of kidneys Dr Wallach okay
um this individual is 170 pounds
five foot oh every all these quit all
these stats I think it was five foot
five
um
she's uh 57
or the person is 57 170 pounds five foot
five inches no diabetes
s um sorry CKD stage three
I'm sorry what stage three
CKD I don't know what that kidney
disease
yes
um and then healed from end stage renal
failure
and then she said or the person says I
use pre prescription prenatal vitamins
and vitamin D3
to help get there okay good so that's a
good start and see if you notice that
she got Improvement just by using some
very simple vitamins and minerals right
the prenatal vitamins vitamin D3 what
170 something pounds to get over all
this okay because it's all just
nutritional deficiencies these get rid
of all the bad stuff so you maximize
absorption no fried foods no processed
Meats uh absolutely no oils no
soundtracks you know cooking oils use
lemon wedges and sweet squirt the juice
on your salads or use yogurt or cream on
your salads instead of oils okay salad
dressing no no no okay then no gluten no
wheat nobody Ryan oats uh no there are
no such things as gluten-free oats the
gluten and oats may be called sometimes
um let's see here what's um
yeah gliadines there you go that's one
of the names gliaden and
um it's still a gluten then no buckwheat
uh buckwheat doesn't have any gluten in
it but it does have Faygo f-a-g-o
Pyrenees in it which is worse than
gluten then no sugar no carbonated
drinks even diet drinks need to go and
also carbonated water because they
neutralize stomach acid so you cannot
absorb minerals to digest food
then at 170 something pounds she needs
two healthy brain and heart pasture
months you know prenatal vitamins may
have
five or six vitamins three or four
minerals and stuff like that so that's
not quite enough it is
um two healthy pain and heart pasture
month photos everything twice a day 215
nutrients in each of those then she
needs two bottles a month of the MSM so
you can take three at breakfast treat
lunch for dinner time they're going to
support and promote mange repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the rotary bone
race bone itself including the bone
marrow to make white blood cells and
antibodies and red blood cells and
platelets and that kind of stuff then
she's a collagen peptides a scoop of
that with morning drinks or the evening
drink
again for the collagen stuff and then we
also wanted to have two bottles a month
of the ultimate daily classic tail it
says three words ultimate daily plastic
tablets take three breakfast treat lunch
or three breakfast three dinner time if
she wants you can have it three times a
day wouldn't hurt but she can no less
than two if she's on blood pressure
medication
um don't cold turkey off of that but as
the blood pressure begins to come down
she can slowly reduce the blood pressure
medication and also this is going to get
the blood flowing into the kidneys and
so she's not a kidney failure patient
anymore kidneys have an enormous
capacity to respond I take people that
haven't urinated
in 10 years zero urination 10 years are
on dialysis six days a week we put them
on that program and in two weeks time
they're urinating so they drop the
dialysis down to three days a week
instead of six days a week then two more
weeks they're totally off the dialysis
and totally blood pressure issues are
gone and but they have these you know
said well how long do I have to stay on
this wall like well how long do you have
to put on your car okay I get it yeah
you need to put you take these nutrients
forever
just because you're getting better or
you're getting ready to travel you can't
quit because then you'll be like your
car
you do not want to have your car go
without oil people treat their cars
better than they treat themselves
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and I I know that she heard that so
that's great information
The Good Foods bad foods list
okay we have a book well no you you've
you've addressed it you went over it the
Good Foods bad foods list Dr Wallach
you're eliminating the things that are
causing the inflammation and damage and
preventing absorption
and preventing absorption absolutely
you're adding foods that are high in
antioxidants high in nutrition
except for the rice but
you're supporting the body so that it
can absorb the nutrients but there's no
nutrients or not enough nutrients in
food
that's why Dr Wallach came up with a
supplementation in these formulas
because it was
going downhill
the more farming the less nutrients the
more population The More Foods being
consumed
the less nutrients in the food two
things that I have to insert number one
plants do not make minerals
plants make vitamins amino acids fatty
acids these are carbon compounds from
plants are famous for taking carbon
dioxide out of the air and making carbon
compounds I don't find them amino acids
and fatty acids nutritional minerals do
not occur in a uniform blank around the
crust of the earth they occur in veins
like gold and silver that's why there's
some areas on Earth where people live a
long time they don't have many of these
type of diseases which we see is common
in certain areas
and then if you take these nutrients
those diseases that are common in
certain areas go away because they're
not a genetic thing they're not an
immune thing your body's not attacking
itself these are simple nutritional
deficiencies even if you have five
people in your family with type 2
diabetes we can get rid of it and you
and them in weeks because it's simple
nutritional efficiency disease it's not
a genetic thing and so this is what we
have going here and we were looking for
teams all over the world we have you
know some big things we're keeping our
fingers crossed here we have potentially
some big things coming
um big numbers of countries and
organizations and stuff lining up
because they realize they're paying for
all these doctors to treat your symptoms
insurance and all that kind of stuff
your employer is a government
we could save
30 percent of the government's
expenditures
okay if everybody would get on the 90th
Century nutrients and stay away from the
bad foods and you wouldn't have any
health issues duh and the government
wouldn't have to pay for all that stuff
and uh it's like crazy it's that simple
and so we we're building an army that I
knew we had to do that when I discovered
this on the birth defects
now way back when in 19
um let's see here
1976 1976 when I discovered that first
monkey was scissorosis I knew that I had
found something extremely useful and it
had to be an army because I'm getting
fired and being fought by all the
biggest medical institutions on Earth
one little guy myself you know a
veterinarian against all these big
medical doctors and Yale and Harvard and
all and all that kind of stuff Nobel
Prize winners are attacking me and so I
had to build an army and so that's why
we took the direction we did to build an
army millions of people who will tell
the story not just me
that's right Dr Wallach because
you're just a little guy
so am I
you're a little girl it takes more than
one voice
to ring throughout the world
and we're just the beginning folks join
us join us join us join us it's an
amazing thing Dr Wallach I had a call
this morning one of my clients reached
out to me had some things going on and
I met him because of youngevity
and being able to calm them just in our
conversation blood pressure
went from 225 over 90 to
178 over 80.
and then figure out okay you've got
these things going on these are the
things that we're going to get going
into your body to help support your body
to do what it was designed to do
it's amazing I love that feeling of
being able to help people Dr Wallach
because we do that and then the next
call we get from them
because I'm Thanking us because things
are better yeah
so now the wallet Revolution comes in it
tells the story over and over and over
75-year
and that's just a handful yeah
it's just some of the big big big ones
yeah
well Dr Wallach we have some more hands
that are up and but we do have a
question here in regards to wheat barley
Ryan oats there's a question can you eat
the micro greens before it goes to seed
before it creates that
that protein in the gluten can you eat
the micro greens of say
wheatgrass barley grass rye grass
can you shoot yourself in the head with
a 22 and no copper jacket
no
okay so the cross-contamination yeah the
cross-contamination there's not as much
in there but it's in there you got to
stay away from it stay away from the
stuff
why do you want to keep getting into
things they're going to kill you
you know the Asians do not eat wheat
brought around oats you know yeah I love
the Chinese they have two cultures one
is in the north they live on wheat their
average life expectancy is 71 and then
in the South they live on rice and sweet
potatoes and seaweed their life
expectancy oh it was 76. okay and so
when you look at these various diseases
they get the ones in the South have
extremely fewer diseases than the ones
in the north and again the life
expectancy uh you can see here uh
in in Japan is 84.7
and they you know they eat like Asians
they live on rice and sweet potatoes and
beans and seaweed and stuff like that
and their life expectancy is 80 84.7 our
life expectancy it's America depend on
whose numbers you're looking at 73 to
75. they live okay nine to ten years
longer than we do
it's not a genetic thing it's not an
unimmune thing it's just a simple
nutritional deficiency thing and that's
why we came out with a book
um let's see here uh
oh here we go immortality we looked at
some of the biggest longest lived
cultures on Earth there you go thank you
the long-slip culture is on Earth
and
what they consciously proactively
avoided that's extremely important but
they proactively avoid it and then what
they proactively ate okay and they all
have very similar sort of um systems
and of course the most recent uh death
or record uh in the industrialized world
not the whole world but the
industrialized World in 1997 Gene
Kellman from France she just died at 122
years 164 days documented by medical
schools okay and so 122 years 164 days
1997 Gene Kellman from France okay
everybody can do that everybody can live
to be 120 too everybody can live to be
140 but you've got to make that a
priority and if um
now drinking soft drinks all have
bubbles in it not taking vitamins
minerals is a big thing for you well go
for it this is America you have your
choice
but um
I think I'm also going to start a coffin
company so I'll have coffins available
for people who don't want to do the
right things
we'll sell them to you for chief
hey it's a free world Dr Wallach if you
want to do that I guess you can do that
but I like being part of this business
so let's focus on helping people so that
they don't need those as early because I
mean if we all have a time to be born
time to die
only the Creator knows when that is so
we're going to support the temple that
he has given us to the best of our
absolute possible ability
and a lot of people don't know how to do
that Dr well like so let's give some
more information on how to do that and
then next question that we're going to
go to is a hand here with us and Kathy
go ahead and unmute yourself
hi Dr Wallach hi
um I am five foot four
um 145 pounds 57 years of age
and I am having
um
histamine response to everything I eat
what does that mean
I get tired
and it happens within 10 minutes of
eating okay you know how who told you it
was a histamine response
I feel it in my body
okay now
um do you have a blood sugar issue do
you ever have do you have diabetes or
low blood sugar not that I know of okay
I think you have reactive hypoglycemia I
want you to go to the drugstore and get
some test strips for your urine and test
strips you know for sticking your finger
and when you eat and then 10 15 30
minutes later you're getting real drowsy
I want you to either urinate on one of
those test strips or stick your finger
better yet stick your finger get a drop
of blood and see what the test strip
says
and I bet you had what's called reactive
hypoglycemia your pancreas is pumping
out an enormous amount of
insulin and so when you eat it pumps out
the insulin it drops your blood sugar
and that's why you go to sleep it's not
an histamine thing
okay and so get you know do the test and
then call us in a a week or 10 days
because you're going to have a great
story because if you if your body weight
give it all the bad foods no fried foods
no processed meat no oils no glutens no
waiting for Orion oats
so buckwheat no uh sugar no carbonation
that's fat no sugar okay no carbonation
including soft drinks also uh no and
sugar-free soft drinks no no no
absolutely no carbonated water those
interference with absorption minerals
and digestive food then we also want you
to have two healthy branded heart
pasture months two Health abandoned
heart patterns photos sitting twice a
day sometimes you get two bottles a
month of our MSM so you take three of
breakfast sweet lunch Street dinner time
and they will support and promote
maintenance repair cart ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
bone response cell take our collagen
peptides go ahead and take the scuba
that with your morning drinks over the
evening drink and then once you get two
bottles a month of our sweeties I want
to take three of those twice a day
okay and you know keep testing yourself
let's say twice a week or three times a
week test your urine once you kind of
get in the mode and keep a little book
and keep you know what's going on there
uh-huh
but I think you have reactor will have
what I've seen and this is why people
get killed uh they cross the highway you
know they're driving and they're falling
asleep because they have reactive
hypoglycemia and they just had a big
dinner they're going home they fall
asleep and cross the highway and do a
head-on and kill themselves and the
other people come the other direction
they say they did a test on them at the
autopsy no drugs in them what happened
they don't know well that's because they
had to have a glycemia reactive
hypoglycemia okay
so why is my body doing that
okay because you're lacking nutrients or
do you eat wheat Brown oats but yeah
well there you go
yeah I just started your diet a couple
days ago okay yeah and so you cannot
efficiently absorb people so I tried
vitamins minerals they didn't work for
me well what do you eat for breakfast I
eat oatmeal every day for my whole life
well that's why because you can't absorb
the nutrition even if you're
supplementing with nutrients you can't
absorb them if you're eating wheat bread
around oats or gluten or buckwheat okay
you need to eat like an Asian stay away
from the bad stuff and you for yourself
you may want to get that book uh Dr
while you're cooking without the bad
foods 300 pages of yeah oh you got that
okay good that's the recipes uh safe
recipes and safe cooking methods and
also it's got the good food bad food
list in there okay if you buy 10 of them
you get a nice I think I don't know if
that may be one of the books you don't
get a discount for that's the exception
Dr Wallach
okay you can buy a hundred of them you
still don't get a discount that one is
flying out the door so fast we don't
need to be offering discounts to
encourage purchasing it okay
and so I also have hair loss but that's
that will be all healed with the
supplements okay well yeah but I want
you if not when you have hair loss you
want to get our hair skin and Nails take
three of those twice it has two bottles
a month they're tiny little bottles okay
so you want to get two bottles a month
of Hair Skin and they'll take through
those twice today
and uh do you have white gray or silver
here
um yes okay well guess what it's not due
to old age it's not due to genetics it's
not too too you know autoimmune things
it's due to nutritional deficiencies now
there's some schools over in Europe that
came out and medical school said oh
there's these special cells in your
scalp that make hair well that's true
and when when they're running amok uh
they will cause you to have gray hair
that's true why are they running amok
because you're missing the nutrients
there's several very special nutrients
they're necessary for those cells to
make
um the hair color whether it's blonde or
red or brown or black okay and so you
need the nutrients for those special
cells to make hair color and so those
cells aren't getting those nutrients
they're not going to make hair color
it's not a autoimmune thing it's not a
genetic thing it's a nutritional
deficiency thing okay
okay and so will this also help my well
will I be able to go off my thyroid
medication oh absolutely now if you have
a thyroid issue and also once you get
two bottles a month of our what we call
Ocean's gold and it's made from nine
seaweeds okay and if you want to take
three of those twice a day I do that I
don't have a I don't have a thyroid
problem but I don't want to have a
thyroid problem so I take three oceans
gold twice a day I also take the few
quite Z three times a day and also nine
seaweeds but it's from the other ocean
okay so I'm getting eight or nine
seaweeds from two different oceans okay
plus I'm getting all the minerals in my
hair my healthy brain and heart pack and
my rebound and all kind of stuff and so
my thyroid is good and that was my first
scientific paper one of those 500 sheep
died they all had thyroid issues because
of pollution from the neighboring Farms
and when the when the drop in
temperature came okay in December of
1963 their thyroids were all dead and
500 sheep they all died in one night
from hypothermia because their thyroids
couldn't keep its body temperature up
they all died of hypo
hypothermia okay and so that was my
first scientific publication 500 died in
one night because of pollution killing
their thyroid glands
uh-huh
okay so yeah your thyroid will come back
it heals very rapidly and so you have to
write notes to your doctors and say you
know you need to find somebody else to
help pay for your kids college because
I'm going to heal myself here so bye bye
yes
thank you so much I will get on top of
that please do contact us every couple
of weeks because you're going to have a
great story okay I I can't wait thank
you so much God bless you okay bye Kathy
welcome to this journey
I brought back from my vacation one of
my old phones that has some of my old
pictures prior to youngevity and the
difference between my hair then and hair
now I've got to do a side by side
graphic because I mean now I it's got so
much life in it and before it was so
thin and couldn't do anything with it
um that's one of the wonderful benefits
that I've experienced with being on the
youngevity products Dr Wallach we've
only got about so five minutes here
um we have Ryan I have two people we
want to get to so Ryan go ahead and
unmute yourself
how can we help you today
I'm sorry yesterday I forgot to mention
that I had um I think I have
hypothyroidism because I have um lower
temperature and puff your face and uh
constipation and the trace elements of
the report from my hair analysis said
that I might be susceptible to
hypothyroidism I looked online uh
regarding about Ocean's code and it has
high calcium so and I also have I have
high calcium to um uh potassium ratio so
I'm not sure if I should be taking um
oceans goat or is that ocean yes
take three twice a day
um but has um calcium do you think that
would aggravate um the ratios no what's
going to happen is your calcium levels
are going to balance out here when you
have something missing or something too
much of something you get on all these
ratios are all screwed up and you can't
you can't pick that thing and say I'm
going to work on that one thing you got
to do the whole picture and this is what
I learned and this is this is where the
medical system is wrong okay when you
have diabetes they will give you a drug
to lower your blood sugar now that
addressing the cause of diabetes no
it'll drop your blood sugar and so
symptomatically you're happy okay and it
might add some time to your life
but because you have all these other
things going wrong all these balances
out of balance all these deficiencies
and so forth and so you're taking
insulin to drop your blood sugar levels
is not the answer
yes
okay so stay stay with your stay with
the ocean's gold and you could go with a
few quiet Z but I also have twice a day
a couple ounces of Z radical which is a
liquid form of fucoid Z
it tastes kind of like red wine but
there's no alcohol in it
it's better than red wine Dr Wallach
well there you go
well okay so let's go
Dr Wall
Nicole go ahead and unmute yourself and
please
thank you for having me um I'm new to
the products I have become a distributor
of youngevity already welcome I'm
excited to get information I have a
niece that has some issues I actually
have a few questions for several people
but my niece she's only like um 16 and
she has something called a pseudotumor
and the doctors have done surgery
where's your pseudo turmer at
it's be it's in her head like behind her
eyes
so there's fluid that keeps getting
behind her eyes and she gets terrible
migraines and they go and withdraw the
fluid okay okay stop
does she complain about any ringing in
her ears you can noise in her ears
anything like that
I am not positive I haven't heard about
it well you need to ask her yeah you
also need to ask her if she has any
balance problems or dizziness
okay okay you also need to ask her how
many times she wakes up at night to
urinate once three times five times does
she complain about urinating all the
time
um let me ask yeah let me ask okay
because I guarantee you she doesn't have
a prostate gland I've never examined her
but she doesn't have a prostate gland
because girlies don't have plastic
glands
um I'm trying to get to that part of the
phone to ask so they're they've done
surgery several times and she keeps
going in and out she has sleep actually
she doesn't sleep well because she does
have very severe sleep apnea and they
said she's
supposedly died many times in her sleep
okay well she could have you know she
could have osteoporosis of the skull
causing all these problems so once you
get a hold of the book and the CD called
it's all in your head
okay it's all in your head
and it deals with 37 different health
problems you get when you have
osteoporosis you know babies are born
with osteoporosis called it's not an
aging thing
okay they get what's called Herb's palsy
they're paralyzed from the neck down
when they're born without osteoporosis
is called because the mother didn't have
enough nutrition to to
provide enough nutrients for the skull
to develop properly okay it's fixable
but you can't just you know treat the
symptoms you got to actually repair the
skull and this book goes into all that
okay and so
um this is going to help you guide you
into treating okay and does this child
also have any voice problems any thing
like that irregular heartbeat fast heart
rate slow heart rate your regular heart
rate
um not that I'm aware of but I'll ask
that yeah you need to ask those
questions and this is where this book
that's on your head will will help you
and of course there's a CD that Rebecca
and I did that goes along with it it's a
set the book and the CD it's on your
head okay
okay thank you and may I ask about
another person her state has something
called Cara
to conitis the cone-shaped eyes and
she's kind of going blind a little bit
your tinnitus
yeah
keratonitis yeah she's 48. okay this is
a eye thing
um this is something where the back of
the eye where the where the
um
optic nerve in the optic arm the optic
vein go into the back of the eye
okay it's called macular the macula
the immaculate regeneration and she may
have macular degeneration here okay
because that part of the eye is dying
because the optic nerve and the optic
artery and vein are being squeezed by
the skull and they have osteoporosis
because it's quite common it's very
common thing and they don't teach it in
medical school when they have
when they have osteoporosis and
arthritis in the knees what do they do
double knee replacement when they have
osteoporosis and arthritis of the hips
or they give no hip replacement
so if doctors were taught about
osteoporosis of the skull
they'd have to give you a double head
replacement
so they don't teach about osteoporosis I
don't even think they know about
osteoporosis Rebecca do you think
doctors know about osteoporosis so you
think both of the people have the exact
same thing oh yeah it's not a genetic
thing if they live in the same house
do you think they eat the same food
I don't think so because the one with
the keratonitis has so many
um
gut and digestion she can barely eat
anything she has nothing she's eating
gluten she's eating wheat Brown oats
you need to get them that book uh Dr
Wallace cooking out the bad foods 300
pages of safe recipes okay uh three all
300 pages also has
um safe cooking methods also it has a
good food bad food list in it this is
something the whole family needs to sit
around and talk about and read that
stuff and ask questions and so on
because when you have two people and the
same two kids in the same family or
brothers and sisters with the same
problem
this is where the doctors come and say
well it's a genetic thing that's why no
people are eating the same way eating
the same food
you know they may have a little
variation but basically they're eating
the same way when they eat gluten wheat
bun around Oats oatmeal for breakfast
and they eat pancakes and waffles uh
they grits and they eat things like um
oh spaghetti oh my gosh there's a killer
spaghetti you can eat rice noodles but
you can't eat wheat noodles
you cannot eat buckwheat noodles okay
and this is where that book doctor
always cooking about the bad food comes
in that book will save your life
okay I'll make sure that they that they
get that
um now I I watched her video and heard
you talk about getting rid of the
muscular dystrophy but I never somehow I
must be missing it never heard
what the answer was I just heard that
you said that you feared it but I never
hear the answers it's a nutritional
deficiency let's just see as a
nutritional deficiency so they got to
get rid of all the bad foods the doctor
always cook them after they have twos
depending on their Asian size uh they
need the 90 essential nutrients the
healthy brain and hard pack uh they need
the collagen peptides they need the MSM
vitamin D3
and glucogel synaptive
and I would also throw in the the I-26
and guess what
I don't care how long you've had muscles
it'll go away
okay so I wrote this down you said
something called i26 E3 collagen
and our collagen Tides our healthy brand
and hard pack
yeah healthy Brandon harpack is is a big
one on this and Nicole I apologize Dr
Wallach does have to get to his next
appointment
um he was just receiving a call from
them so Dr Wallach
thank you again so much
and yes please come back Nicole
um I know as a new health coach I was
wondering where can I get answers and I
love the fact that I now am able to
provide this program to help all of our
health coaches get
answers so that they can then work
within their own health their own
families their own communities and all
together will eventually reach the world
if I could get my co-hosts up with me
that would be fantastic I want to thank
them individually for all that they do
we have Farhan Farhan is helping make
sure everybody gets in he's helping
watch the cameras and also make sure
that we have the sounds out in the
different
um
platforms like Facebook and YouTube and
Rumble and we are expanding so if you
have a favorite one I know Rumble was a
favorite one the last time I asked
um where do you watch videos we want to
make sure that we are reaching where the
people are watching I want to thank
Marilyn pazera for all of the work that
she's doing and she's putting
information in the chat for people to be
able to see who are here with us and as
Dr Wallach is recommending these
products she's then transcribing that
putting it in the chat so folks if you
want to come and join us Monday through
Friday from 12 to 12 50-ish Pacific time
you are welcome to daily with Doc
zoom.com is where you want to go
Sherry Browning who is also helping us
keep track of the questions that are
coming in through the chat she takes
pictures of it sends it to me and
hopefully I get to it if not we still
have record of that so that if we can
tell who the person is and we have
contact information for that person we
can then reach out to that person with
the answers to the questions that
they're asking and then last but not
least we have my sister Ruth Ellen
Sanchez who is helping me make sure that
all of my Graphics look right make sure
that everything is being streamed where
it's supposed to be streamed with sound
and
keeping me on track when I go on my
little Side Tracks so my name is Becca
dukes and as the hostess of daily with
Doc I am so proud of my team
folks if you're lucky to be part of a
community
we have community that is waiting for
you
we're health-minded we love people we
are not close to the fact that we are
Divine creations
what we put in our body what we feed our
body
is going to determine how our body is
going to respond
and we're important I hope you feel that
too I hope you understand that if you
don't you need to surround yourself with
people who can help you feel that help
you understand that
we had so many questions coming on today
I know that every single one of you is
important all of your questions are
important
if we did not get to your question today
and you would like to ask please go to
daily with
doc.com use that contact us send us an
email let us know if you're working with
a health coach or not so that we can
make sure that your health coach knows
that you have in questions and then we
can get answers to both of you so they
can continue to coach you with using Dr
wallach's recommendations
okay that's the most important part Dr
Wallach has done so much research he has
taken his research and put it to work
both in the animal world and in the
human world he's created formulas
because he couldn't find what he was
looking for so he put a team together
that then put what he was looking for
into formulas that were absorbable by
the body
we can't absorb Rock but folks when
plants take up that rock into their
roots and create the nutrients within
the plant that then we eat or the meat
that we eat eats so that we get
nutrients that way
it just makes for a much better outcome
much better tomorrow when it comes to
our health and our Wellness both
physically and mentally and
yeah thank you oh I cannot forget I
cannot forget AJ out on YouTube doing
such a fabulous job Sportacus and I'm
gonna get it right
thank you so much for helping out out
there on YouTube with all of the the
questions and we will make sure that we
get answers to those who reach out to us
so until next time thank you everybody
for taking time out of your schedule
don't forget to get back with the person
that shared this program with you and
say thank you thank you for caring
enough for taking the time to share this
video with me because
I don't know about you but even as I'm
listening
and hearing what things are affecting
other people it brings more and more
people to my mind that I need to reach
out to
and as health coaches we have Solutions
bye for now
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign